queen elizabeth is back to work
virtually and a source tells e.t she's
zooming with family members everything
at the palace is business as usual
ticking along and far from alarm bells
clanging there really is no real concern
about the queen's health the courtiers
i've spoken to have used the word
cautious more than any sense of alarm so
i think we should be focusing on that
rather than any sensationalists and
false reports that people may be reading
and hearing about online on tuesday the
95 year old monarch was seen for the
first time since false rumors of her
death last month following a positive
covid19 test there has been concern over
the queen's health since the palace
confirmed that she has been diagnosed
with covid and understandably so she's
95 her age alone makes her vulnerable i
have spoken to senior palisades who
assure me that the queen is in good
spirits and she's suffering cold-like
symptoms and that is why she chose to
cancel a recent virtual audience i think
anyone that's got a cold and a runny
nose just not feeling 100
the last thing they want to do is be on
camera after postponing several virtual
events due to her illness the queen is
back to business as usual popping up on
two virtual gatherings where she dialed
in from windsor castle that's hrh
looking regal as ever in green appearing
to be in good spirits and now a source
is opening up to e.t about her return to
work explaining that she's on the mend
and has been zooming with family members
and handling light duties from her
apartment at the castle quote the queen
had a sore throat and was a bit croaky
with cold-like symptoms but is doing
better the queen is in good spirits
she's suffering a cold bit of a red nose
bit of a sniffle but really not much
more than that and while queen elizabeth
previously avoided virtual appearances
amid her coveted battle etie learned at
the time that she was still carrying on
with work i'm told that the queen is at
her desk she's doing light duties she's
reading her government papers she's got
her red boxes being delivered to her
daily so
i take that as an indication that she is
not quite feeling up to being on camera
understandably so but absolutely up to
doing light duties and some desk-based
work so i think that's all very
encouraging last week a source confirmed
to et that the royal had her weekly call
with united kingdom prime minister boris
johnson normally the conversation would
have been held in person but due to the
queen's positive covid test the two
spoke over the phone in addition to
delaying several virtual events the
queen also postponed a diplomatic
reception planned to take place
wednesday at windsor castle due to the
ongoing conflict between ukraine and
russia